my favorite movie forest the gum you
know life is tough this is I learned and
that inspired me if you want to win in
business you have to think bigger than
the service or product you provide I
feel like if I didn't have music I don't
know what I would have rise and shine it
since press'll time
good morning belief nation my name is
Alex and my one word is belong I believe
that the world would be a better place
if more people felt that they belong so
to start off your day right grab a cup
of coffee and sip on today's message
think big over to you Jack Ma every five
years we have a review for our strategy
now our strategy is always to look at
the 30 years and 10 years every
strategic decisions we make we have to
ask one question this decision we make
solve society problem because we believe
the biggest social property you solved
the most successful you are so if we do
it this cannot solve any social problems
we don't do it second is this project is
going to be successful in 10 years if
it's it's going to be successful in 10
years
let's do it if it's going to be
successful in one year or one month
normally I say forget about it because
why you can be successful in one year or
one mouth so we all have to put Parham
and five years ago we had a big debate
about 10 years later 20 years what are
the things this china society the world
leave want so we say happiness and
health to h strategy to happiness and
health we believe Holly do you know the
movie industry bring people happy
because today nobody is happy
rich people are happy poor people not
happy you know
at least when I watch movie after you're
happy but right so I think we should
have partner with the Hollywood
especially like a lot of you know we
have a different way of living and in
China the movie we have a lot of heroes
but China movies heroes always dead the
American me movie here will never die if
all the heroes die who want to be the
hero so my movie I want to make the hero
live right so this is this is I think we
should learn a lot and it's all about
two years so we have another eight years
ago I want to make our company that it's
it's not ecommerce it's something that
giving people inspirations given people
because I learned a lot for example I
will say that my favorite movie Forrest
the gun you know life is tough this is I
learned and that inspired me that is why
when people call me crazy stupid pasta
70 years you're crazy I do you something
never work
you're stupid how can do that model
Evers in this model eBay this model why
about this model I told myself for is
the gum set or a hat that will care
about what the other people and the
other thing Forrest Gump said nobody
make money out of the catching whales
people make money by catching shrimps so
we serve small business or not if you
want to win in business you have to
think bigger than the service or product
you provide a Toronto dance salsa we
don't just focus on how to do a right
turn Tirana dance salsa is the largest
dance school in Canada and the reason
that we got so big was because we looked
outside of the moves that we teach all
the tricks all the turns all the dips
all the tosses in the air did it matter
as much as the experience we provided to
students every person wants to feel
loved every person wants to feel like
they belong but they want to feel wanted
appreciated validated and
see and so we've always at our school
thought bigger we thought about they may
come in for a service but they come back
and they refer others because we enrich
their lives we focus on the essential
human needs like love like care like
belonging that across cultures across
demographics everybody wants to feel or
experience I love Jack Maas message
thinking five or 10 years from now
because what people are worried about
let's say right now for the next six
months it's gonna come and go but what
stands the test of time are the deep
down worries and fears that we all share
so if you want to have a successful
business you have to think bigger than
the service or product you provide
because people may come to your dance
school people may come to your coffee
shop by random chance but that's not
what's gonna keep them there and that's
not what's gonna make them refer clients
to you now I've got a special bonus clip
for you but before we get to it
today's question is how have you been
thinking small in your business and what
can you do to change that to really make
an impact on your customers leave it in
the comments below and we look forward
to hearing what you have to say thank
you so much for watching we believe in
you and we hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is we'll see you tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso enjoy the bonus
clip
let's pray so give me go
when I look back at my life I feel like
if I didn't have music I don't know what
I would have I have my friends and my
family but music gave me a purpose when
I was bullied in school it gave me the
motivation to keep going and prove to
everyone that didn't believe in me that
I was gonna be something someday I look
back and I look at someone who slept 18
hours a day use drugs everyday and then
you see someone today who's inspired to
make better music to talk about her own
story to help other people and to make
the world a better place and that's a
miracle she has lived through a lot of
stuff and she tries to put that stuff
into her art because she's so authentic
and that's why people love her she
doesn't come in and go well I need a hit
she comes in with a passion for this is
how I'm feeling right now and this is
how the people that I know listen to my
music review there's other great singers
out there but like Demi's voices Timmy's
voice and Debbie's attitude is Debbie's
attitude
I know what music can get you through I
know what music can do emotionally for
somebody because I've experienced it
myself and I wanted to create that for
other people there's nothing more
beautiful than being able to connect
with people through music a - I
understand the importance of me having a
voice and exposing people beyond you
know the typical ballet world to this
art form I think it saved my life and I
want to introduce it to more people and
you know coming full circle that's
something that I'm trying to do now is
to give back to those communities
through Boys and Girls Clubs being an
alum to invite people into my world as
it's happening I think it's really
amazing to have grown men that you know
never have seen a ballet in their life
look at me and see a woman that they can
relate to someone who looks like their
sister their daughter their mother and
to say well I'm gonna put my child and
not because they can see themselves
through you I think it's creating a
completely different path for these
people that never saw themselves in this
world and to watch me still growing in
and on my path I think is really
powerful
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core values is that we believe that
people with passion can change
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top 10 rows of success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details